in this segment we introduce the subject
of list mean squares estimation but as a
warm-up we will start with a very simple
special case suppose that we have some
random variable that we wish to estimate
and that we have the probability
distribution of this random variable the
probability mass function if it's
discrete or a probability density
function if it's continuous as a
concrete instance suppose that our
random variable is uniformly distributed
over a certain interval we would like to
estimate this random variable we're
interested in a point estimate
however we look at the very special case
where there are no observations
available all that we have is this
probability distribution how do we
estimate this random variable well we
can use the rules that we have already
developed for example the maximum a
posteriori probability rule what would
it do in this case since there are no
observations the posterior distribution
of theta is the same as the prior there
are no observations that would change
the prior so we need to find the point
at which this distribution is highest
well because this distribution is flat
the map rule does not give us a unique
answer any value of theta inside the
interval from 4 to 10 would be an
acceptable answer so any particular
estimate in this interval would be fine
so this rule is not particularly helpful
how about a different estimator we have
seen the conditional expectation
estimator once more in our case since we
do not have any observations the
conditional expectation is the same as
the expectation and for this particular
example it would give us the midpoint of
the distribution namely an estimate
equal to 7 now this rule was
inconclusive
this rule gave us a number how can we
choose and decide that one of these is
the right estimate we can do that if we
introduce a specific performance
criterion what is it that we wish from
our estimators
and the particular criterion the one
that we will be focusing on is the mean
squared error if you come up with a
certain estimate you look at how far is
your estimate from the true value that
you are trying to estimate take the
square that and average it and this
leads us to a formulation who are by we
will try to find an estimate theta hat
that minimizes this mean squared error
over all possible estimates let us now
look at this formulation and see how we
can solve it this is a function of a
single variable theta hat and we can try
to minimize it using conventional
methods to carry out this minimization
let us first expand this expectation
into a sum of terms we have the expected
value of the square of the random
variable then a cross term minus 2 the
expected value of theta times theta hat
however theta hat is a number that we're
trying to choose it's not random
therefore we can pull it outside the
expectation and similarly the last term
the expected value of theta hat squared
is just theta hat squared itself this is
what we want to minimize how do we
minimize it we take the derivative with
respect to theta hat and set it to 0 and
this gives us minus 2 the expected value
of theta plus twice theta hat equal to 0
and when we solve this we find that
theta hat the optimal estimate is equal
to the expected value of theta so this
is the answer to our optimization
problem the optimal estimate according
to the least squares criterion is the
expected value of the random variable
now it's interesting to derive this
result also in a second way since it is
a quite important than phantom
the result let us see whether there is a
different way of establishing it that
stays closer to the probabilistic world
rather than the calculus world so let us
look at this criterion that we have here
the expected value of the square of a
random variable is always equal to the
variance of that random variable plus
the expected value of that random
variable squared this is what we are
trying to minimize now theta hat is a
constant the variance of a random
variable plus or minus a constant is the
same as the variance of that random
variable and there is nothing that we
can do about this term
so what we are trying to do is
essentially just try to minimize this
term with respect to theta hat now here
we have the square of something the way
to minimize this is to try to make this
quantity as small as possible make it
zero if we can well we can make it zero
if we set theta hat equal to the
expected value of theta so this term
here is minimized when theta hat is
equal to the expected value of theta it
is minimized because this is a choice
that will make this term equal to 0 so
this was a second derivation of why this
is the optimal estimate of theta once we
adopt this particular estimate the mean
squared error is going to be equal to
this because this is our theta hat and
of course we recognize that this is the
variance so the variance of theta is the
least possible value of the mean squared
error that we can obtained using any
particular estimate
and this is our final conclusion and in
the next segment we will exploit the
conclusions that we found here and apply
them to a more general situation